[Música]
y en nuestra sección de economía hoy nos
acompaña nuestro periodista jorge
hurtado jorge bienvenido qué tal me
declara tu sección favorita me han dicho
mi sección favorita por supuesto
iniciamos nuestra sección favorita
hablando del impacto de la subida de los
diferentes tipos de interés en eeuu buen
hombre clara y es que un día después del
mejor día de 2022 para la bolsa en eeuu
las acciones se desplomaron por el
aumento de tasas que hizo la reserva
federal de eeuu la mayor en dos décadas
el de sant y 500 que aglutina las
empresas más grandes de ese país cayó un
3,6 por ciento el nasdaq donde están las
empresas de tecnología se dio un 5 por
ciento y es un su mayor caída desde
junio de 2020 mientras el down jones de
industriales perdió un 3 12 por ciento
algunos analistas prevén que esto apenas
es el inicio de un ciclo de
endurecimiento de la política monetaria
en ese país las acciones europeas por su
parte cayeron por segunda sesión
consecutiva tras los comentarios de la
reserva federal y bueno pesimismo
también se apoderó de los mercados de
américa latina que siguieron la estela
de los mercados mundiales y a pesar de
estas presiones jorge la opep tsja es el
grupo de países productores y
exportadores de petróleo decidieron
aumentar la producción porque aunque lo
hicieron tímidamente el grupo acordó
agregar tres 432 mil barriles por día a
partir de junio el plan es hacer esos
aumentos regulares para restaurar los
recortes durante la pandemia la
fluctuación en los precios del petróleo
afecta a los consumidores de eeuu europa
con una inflación galopante que los
bancos centrales buscan contener los
precios del petróleo por ejemplo son los
más altos en 8 años pero la opep tiene
el poder de bajar estos precios poniendo
más petróleo en el mercado algo que eeuu
y el reino unido han pedido pero que no
han sido escuchados la guerra en ucrania
supuso también un incremento en los
mercados petroleros en los últimos días
sobre todo ahora que el órgano ejecutivo
de la unión europea dijo que eliminará
gradualmente las importaciones de
petróleo ruso en un plazo de seis meses
también un comité del senado de eeuu
aprobó un proyecto de ley que podría
exponer a la opep ya sus socios a
demandas por colusión en el aumento de
los precios del crudo y aunque las
versiones de esta ley han fracasado en
el congreso durante más de dos décadas
ahora más que nunca los legisladores
están preocupados por este aumento de
los precios jorge ya propósito de los
precios altos reino unido decidió
aumentar la tasa de interés una decisión
que ya habían tomado eeuu y brasil como
lo habíamos visto en nuestra sección
porque el banco de inglaterra elevó los
tipos de interés en el reino unido- del
0.75 por ciento hasta el 1% y es un
nivel más alto en 13 años esta es la
cuarta vez consecutiva que los miembros
del comité de política monetaria de esa
entidad elevan los tipos de interés a
fin de controlar la inflación que el
pasado marzo se situó en el 7% su nivel
más alto en 30 años la inflación mundial
ha crecido bruscamente tras invasión
rusa de ucrania además de las
restricciones del cob y 19 en china que
están empeorando los problemas en la
cadena de suministro a las que reino
unido no está a salvo recientemente el
gobernador del banco de inglaterra
alertó de que la entidad camina sobre
una línea muy fina entre el objetivo de
controlar la inflación y evitar así una
recesión económica y esa inflación es
histórica en turquía donde los precios
han aumentado casi un 70 por ciento en
un año supone también un desafío para el
presidente de tayyip erdogán cuyas
políticas económicas han provocado el
desplome de esa economía el índice de
precios del consumo aumentó 69 97 por
ciento interanual en abril frente al 61
14 por ciento de marzo según la agencia
nacional de estadística perdonen insiste
en recortar los tipos de interés para
reducir los precios al consumo en contra
la ortodoxia económica y de lo que están
haciendo los demás bancos centrales del
mundo la caída de la libra que es la
moneda oficial disparó los costos de las
importaciones energéticas las mayores
subidas de los precios en abril
correspondieron al sector del transporte
con 105 9% interanual mientras que los
precios de los alimentos y las bebidas
no alcohólicas' se dispararon un 89,1
por ciento con respecto a hace un año
'jorge gracias por toda la información
económica y nosotros seguimos con más en
directo américa
[Música]